you beautifully dedicate my body to your
son sylvester i think that there's a lot
that i hope you can learn from it a huge
fellow britney spears fan you talk about
her extensively in your essay toxic at
one point i almost was like i have to
take that part out of the book the
brittany part is this book my body sort
of your way of reclaiming your narrative
as a model and an actress you're always
a part of someone else's visions and it
felt really amazing to to become someone
who is the creator
emily ratakowski so good to see you
congratulations
on releasing my body you're releasing
this baby into the world what is your
ultimate goal i was really
wanted to talk about power dynamics i
hope that women in general feel like
there are things in my experience that
they can relate to about being a woman
about the kind of um
you know dance that women do to both you
know feel beautiful
to
sometimes cover themselves up to to
really sexualize themselves um
and how they can kind of get ahead and
also feel taken advantage of at the same
time in the way that they have to
experience that
i want them to relate to that um i hope
that you know for men
um
that they're able to feel some
compassion and understand what it's like
to be a woman you know at this point
everything that you say is is picked
apart hyperanalyzed turned into a
headline how have you learned to live in
that space and is this book my body sort
of your way of reclaiming your narrative
absolutely i think one of the biggest
themes in the book is control and
obviously i made this book i you know
court every over every sentence and
every word choice and the ultimate act
of control um and making something too i
mean as a model and an actress you're
always a part of someone else's vision
someone else's photograph melts this
project and it felt really amazing to to
become someone who is the creator um
that you know being said you i've
watched you know little things
information leaks stories leak and
things be turned into things they're
just not um and i know that the world
consumes
media in that way um but i'm really
excited that the book's gonna finally be
available for people to to have the even
option and the opportunity to read
things in my own words what would you
tell younger emily who had to read
things and see google alerts you know
now that you're 30 years old and you
have a lot more security with yourself i
even find myself like it's very easy to
just look at a headline and make an
opinion and not have to take the extra
30 seconds to read the article um and i
think we're all guilty of that might be
myself as well um so i think that you
know just in general now being someone
who's in the public eye and has
experienced that so much i really
encourage people to have a healthy
little bit of disbelief of and and
wanting you know and just understand
that these these headlines are designed
for people to click on them essentially
read the article before you share it how
about that yeah yeah right
um two-parter here i'm curious which was
the essay that was hardest to relive as
you were writing it and which one is
most daunting about releasing it into
the world hardest to relive um was
buying myself back which was published
in the cut a year ago i
when i first wrote it i thought oh wow
this was really bad writing and i'll
never share it again but i just had to
write about it for myself and that's
fine it took sort of other people and me
revisiting it and saying okay actually i
think this is worth sharing um and then
the one that i'm you know the most
nervous to put out in the world but it
sort of already happened is blurred
lines because i just didn't want to
write it because i knew that the
headlines that were you know going to
come out of it um that it would turn
into this like juicy bit of gossip and
that you know the other more nuanced
or even there's the nuance of that
particular story would be lost in in the
media frenzy i know and how are you
feeling about all that i'm feeling okay
now that the book's about to be
available um you know i feel just really
happy with
the way that people are talking about
the book and i'm just very much looking
forward to the public having access to
it you're in good company huge fellow
britney spears fan you've talked about
her on your social media you talk about
her extensively in your essay toxic have
you sent her the book have you had a
chance to connect with her i haven't um
i feel like a lot of people are kind of
sending her things and you know whatever
um
i you know
i think what she represented at one
point i almost was like i have to take
that part out of the book the brittany
part because i just felt like so many
people were writing about her and
talking about her and i didn't want to
just like
make it like jump on that kind of
bandwagon then actually interestingly by
the time you know i was finishing the
book and it was going to be completed i
was like of course i have to talk about
her now she she represents something in
the zeitgeist but i don't know her
personally if she gets a chance to read
it how do you hope she feels i know what
it's like i mean to be written about as
something that represents someone else's
life and it doesn't always
mean as much to you as it does maybe the
person who's writing about it so um you
know i hope she reads the book but i
also
um hope she just is happy
yeah i know i think that's what we're
all feeling inside right yeah you
beautifully dedicate my body to your son
sylvester
and i imagine one day he'll grow up he
might be curious about the book he might
want to read it are there parts where
you're like oh gosh maybe you could skip
over that part and is there a part where
you're like i hope he pays special
attention to that i dedicated the book
to him because i wrote about these
experiences to make myself the best
version of a mother that i could see and
that's you know i think really it was
about love and that's why i wrote the
book and i think that there's a lot that
i hope you can learn from it but again
he's such a baby right now i'm just
interested in keeping him safe and happy
[Music]